So let's go ahead and talk about briefly
about what we covered today.
What we looked at first was we looked at expanding materials
and allowing us to be able to open up parameters
within the material to be able to control UVs,
as well as looking at the static switch parameter.
Next, we looked at masking materials
and how to edit those within one material,
allowing us to be able to mask texture elements
in the material to make it look like it's two materials
when it really is one.
And then we looked at masking materials
when it came to RGB channels,
how they work and how it is done.
Looking at each one of the variables
and looking at that texture
and how the RGB channels are nested within one texture.
And then finally, we looked at material functions.
In the material function,
we looked at how we can use material functions
when it comes to using a light function.
And we broke down how that works
and using those function inputs
to be able to get things allocated and accessible
within a parent material.
Well, that's it.
I hope you enjoyed this class
and you learned a few things.
And see you next time.